uh magnus plays one move
with it plays one more then i blender
then bishwa blenders
so that's how it will go ahead don't
worry magnus i got your back
[Music]
okay so it's my move now okay uh
c5 i hope this is unrated challenge
you play very well magnus thank you
thank you
somewhere do you feel any pressure today
a lot how bad will you feel if you screw
up
can you uh magnus keep like appreciating
me in the middle like good move or
something so i
feel good oh um
no i played bishop d3 got it uh
uh okay okay okay okay okay okay
bishop g5 perfect very good
we should just not blunder anything that
should be the strategy just
play normal chess yeah not like we were
playing a world champion
no no no don't worry i scared you play
normal don't worry
just play normal yo i i can't play
normally i now have a plan bro
queen e3 no no planning
i have a plan bro where's the plan
i don't see the plan my plan is failed
i'm sorry i'm sorry to report i have no
plan
sorry with it i apologize later
no no no be optimistic we have a decent
position see why i played a3 think about
it
for no reason you don't you don't
have any other moves that is so dirty
that's so dirty i i see your plan and
this is really dirty
okay with it i'm going to uh do a move
um or should i not just just do move
don't do a move you know that doesn't
have a good sound
c4 very good move genuinely
no this one it's okay don't listen to
them
don't listen huh oh oh brother getting
maximum pressure just simple simple he
attacked
hey hey we don't attack anything
nothing is simple you know what with it
i'm sorry
no no don't be so over think think think
what do you say
g4 you should be sorry
you should be sorry i'm sorry i can't
handle this pressure anymore
f4 check very good
man there's a free palm samai there's no
trick
what do i do now do you feel like
committing
i feel like committing a blender
yeah we are winning okay so uh
anymore
oh man oh man oh man oh oh
a queen takes h3
play play
[Music]
oh my god
okay
[Music]
oh another draw so okay
magnus are you first of all having fun
with us i i had a lot of fun but
uh now that we didn't win the last game
i'm having a long time
we had the last segment which we call
dice chess
dice chess it's a new innovation in
chess with this is already smiling
magnus do you know about dice chess
no it's gonna i but i have a feeling
it's gonna get dicey
now let's go so a magnus with the white
pieces and i'm rolling the dice and it
says
it says illegal move so let's begin okay
it's gonna be night or palm
yeah it's night okay it's night sure
okay uh we'll go with uh we'll go with
the knight
with it a bishop a queen or a king hmm
that's not a good choice no it's it's
not
a knight a bishop or a king
[Music]
this is not a chance it's a
born a rook or a queen
let's go nasty magnus let's see how good
you are at math
what is the probability of getting all
the three
same uh so that's three times one out of
six
how much is that i i
no risk still you can get rewarded
it's a queen a knight or a bishop
okay we gotta go for it no
oh man magnus has taken a risk okay
night somebody give me a night a
pond a queen and a
king yes yes
i told you with it big risks big rewards
i think we can just
move to normal just don't know we don't
need the dice anymore no
okay fine fine we just need like 10
good rolls of dice in a row now
and we'll be fine we're getting back in
the game so you just have to gamble yet
that's what i realized
it's it's unlearn and learn fantastic
will you gamble how have you not given
me a pawn
ever the fault in all stars
[Music]
oh
let's make it fun i mean what's the
point
it's a king king and a rook
see you have to gamble at the right spot
yeah
you have a queen bishop knight okay
okay that's game over it's checkmate
yes oh it's checkmate oh no oh man
so that is i think i'm sure that magnus
is never playing dice just again
ever okay next time we're going to play
card chess
definitely done so happy to see you here
magnus thanks for joining
really no thank you it was it was great
fun and
lots of lots of good inventions and
some decent chess actually uh magnus
please invite more
indian players in your image okay okay
it would get very awkward all right
magnus it was a pleasure having you
thank you so much for coming i hope you
also had fun because we had a
great time and uh thank you thank you i
had a great time
thank you i hope uh we can do something
together once more maybe
you know later maybe karcher something
that you win uh you know apart from the
normal chess
that you always win let's hope yes let's
play card chess next time yes thank you
so much for coming magnus see you